you can answer questions wrong i don't
believe you i didn't buy any of that i
was lying and still win a million
dollars all you need is one of these
people to believe your story how am i
supposed to talk about your show when i
can't even say the word on air so what i
do is because you can't say
you just call it the
show this
is
problem solved are you a good bs
detector again
i'm talking to you three now
does she know the answer
or is it bs
no i'm not a good bs detector as much as
i am a deliverer of bs
i'm great at that
you would not know
that i'm delivering that
you sold that on me and i believe yes
and that's exactly what the game is you
don't know the answers and you walk out
of there with a million dollars
it's the cgt judges in order to go to
the next level to the finals they gotta
step it up i really love you on canada's
got talent who do you think is going to
win and will you do another season in
canada and can i have front row seats
because i want to watch
is this an exclusive are you giving me
an announcement
yeah let's figure it out i think you
should bring it back just do it i'll
just do it so it'll just be me and you
in the room if nobody else asks us back
um so so yes i would love to come back
and you can have fun no you can't have
front row seats i have front row seats
fine i'll sit behind you then behind
every great man
[Music]
is a hickey
[Music]
that's amazing
yes